on this episode I didn't really deep on
that last question don't fast forward
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 201 of
the askgaryvee show
all right we're into the 200th Monday
morning feeling good about that
do you rock doing some snaps over here
we're taping a daily be today which I'm
very excited about you're not you're not
filming right you're just gonna look
because we've got this right if you want
to take a quick little sample you'll do
that
Indian great to see you is that a San
Francisco Giants what you guys are
debating about that that's really cool I
like it I noticed
India are you ready for the show I'm
ready for the show uh Colin shows a lot
of fun I enjoyed that I want to do that
I think we have some things to figure
out Andy did we uh
I really wish this was a Colin show but
I feel like we'd have time to talk about
like the kinks I feel like there's kinks
all right but I think 202 or two or
three I want to do it so like I want to
dress kinks all right uh so we are now
into the next frontier episode 200 to
300 you know I'm really curious how long
I'm gonna actually do this like I don't
feel it wavering don't worry but um I do
think it's like I would I would say that
I was positive I'd get to 200 I'm not
positive I get to 300 I can see us doing
something weird and being at 267 being
like that's it you know so I really do
believe that all right 267 will be well
I'll be watching that alright India
let's get into the show the wealth life
asks how do you deal with people who
don't keep their word
um well psych I'll be very honest with
you I think one of the great secrets of
my business success and life in general
is zero expectation of others I know I
know that a lot of people get mad at me
when I say that in my life in my
business life at when I say it in public
but it's my truth I mean I'm just not
that devastated it's a data point people
don't keep their word all the time India
it happens all the time as a matter of
fact it's probably the thing that I
struggle with the most and being the CEO
of this company a lot of people have
worked in other places where the person
kept their word and their cynical - my
word and so Ellison hi by the way
I even kept my word my whole life even
now because something may fall through
the Inbox
like you see what's going on now right
like I know that like I promised to give
a shout out or a birthday wish and I
miss it there's human error in women in
not keeping your word and then there's
just not keeping your word which happens
often it's a reality humans are flawed
and I would tell you that the biggest
differentiation between myself and many
others if I'm self evaluating that has
been a big deal for me is I just don't
cry there's no crying in business like
like you know it how do i deal with it i
move on i collect datum like uh Stefan
doesn't keep his word very often so his
word is not as valuable to me so I'm
gonna take it with a grain of salt that
he's gonna actually link this up you
know and so you know whatever it may be
I think it's something that you know up
I don't like entitlement like and I do
think believe it or not I do think that
people get upset with others from a
level of entitlement more than anything
else like sorry wreck what sorry wealth
he'll miss or what wealth life like
sorry that you know entrepreneur life
let you down and didn't post that thing
like I you know I it is what it is
what it is like I just I just let stuff
roll off my back
it is what it is I'm just prepared for
the the negative and and so I'm
completely unfazed by it I'm like oh
that was intriguing like not like oh
like screwed me I've been sabotaged
like I'm Owen and I failed because India
didn't come through with her we're like
Oh Olga V screwed me or like like
business put on your pants your big boy
and big girl pants and get to work and
so you know I I contact I sit I use it
as a data set for my next business
behavior with that individual or
organization and I just move on and and
I don't do well and I go forward people
to people slow themselves down
Thanks it's true it's true it's like
like it's the game like I'm sorry like
people gonna let you down people are not
gonna come through like stuff that like
almost nothing turns out the way I
wanted to it's the ability to adjust to
that that separates winners and losers
in the business world Justin Timberlake
this is Justin Timberlake Bieber
whatever doesn't you want to be right
now okay really neither I'll tell you
later
Novello ah Justin asks if you were
building a retail biz
what trend would you be paying the most
attention to Justin this is a silly
question I mean all of them like when
what do you mean what trend all of them
how people are shopping on mobile you
know how bricks and mortars are still
very viable health and wellness
meditation you know technology like not
there's no one trend to pay attention to
I'm not going to give you there's no
secret that there's no episode 201 maybe
Gary will answer my question and give me
some incredible insight they're all in
play all the trends matter mobile
commerce people shopping behaviors
real-time delivery and then all the
genres of things you can be selling
right like just a million things people
are into like he and yoga pants and you
know like I don't know I mean this this
question is kind of exhausting and I'm
not mad at you Justin Novello it's just
uh it's just it's a silly question
because they're all matter I pay
attention to everything I can as much as
possible Justin as many things as
possible they're all data sets they all
can lead to opportunity uh you know
that's what I would pay attention to
like there's a million things going on
there's 75 different pillar core things
that are going on in retail the lack of
people traveling to malls you know like
you know postmates same-day delivery
like you know down towns and cities
emerging again you know you know the
gender fication of neighborhoods like
you know fashion trends what people are
drinking
eating like sneaker swag like I you know
accessories on cellphones everything
that's happening in Asia that one out of
every seven times happens in the US like
I don't know all of it Malita asks if we
aren't good with numbers can we really
be good at business I'm [ __ ] with
numbers next Andy by the way I'm not
that [ __ ] with numbers but I'm very
average what's up Gary this is an the
underscore Barden on blank it up here in
the Teton Mountains in Wyoming I know
you say you want to climb that goddamn
mountain how do you think nature affects
your brain and do you take time to get
outside Thanks
and a great question beautiful setting I
do like the videos the job India for
picking one I do want more videos in
beautiful places Andy this is one look
nature's not at the forefront of it for
me but I think a lot of people use it I
have a ton of entrepreneurial friends
who rock climb run marathons at a
meeting this morning with Mark Evans
that you'll see in the LAV
he's running 40 races first 40th
birthday year and you know that's how he
escapes and that's how he keeps his
mental health and I think nature is an
incredible incredible driver for so many
I'm so thankful for nature in many ways
obviously just what it is in society but
from a business standpoint I've watched
entrepreneur after entrepreneur after
entrepreneur really get an enormous
value from you know walking trails to
you know surfing to like it's incredible
it's not my thing um it's just not and
you know I really don't care about part
of pretty sunsets I have no interest in
ever going on a mountain trail I've just
none you know beautiful fields are not
interesting to me I would be like oh we
can build homes here and make money like
like a you know it's just you know it's
not who I am but that doesn't mean that
it doesn't bring enormous value to
people and I watch a lot of people
your go-to you know the mountain even
you know a lot of people that work in
vain or love working in LA in San
Francisco because they provide so much
of that I've watched the New York crew
do the best they can into the you know
upper Westchester or the Vermont's or
the mains or you know things of that
nature they're all probably getting
pumped because we're getting that time
of year where nature plays a little bit
of a bigger role so many get so much
value even look at the body language of
these three like it's awesome it's just
not how I escaped I escaped really in
weird ways I escaped with the Jets the
Jets matter so much to me that's how I
escaped and through this I don't uh you
know I work out obviously seven days a
week now as you guys know but I'm doing
a lot of that indoors so I don't know
I'm just not going to nature I've never
been you know mother nature and I have
respect but not uh not love yep this is
Vaness I'm 15 years old
my question is whenever someone puts you
down how do you push yourself back up
Vaness you know it's tougher when you're
15 as you're building your self esteem
and and your foundation of your life you
know I know so but listen if you're 45
and there's 62 I mean there's so many
people right now they're not doing what
they love because they're worried about
what other people think or what other
people say especially your inner family
we've talked about this at length I'm
very passionate about this I'm so
grateful that I don't give a crap what
anybody thinks of me while equally
caring it's incredibly important to me
what in your d-roc or Stefan think of me
it's incredibly important it's stunning
though how how anti-establishment or how
much I would push back when they would
try to impose their will on me and
that's a very important differentiation
actually that's one of the first times
I've ever kind of articulated this way
and I like this there's a very big
difference between what one thinks of
you and what one tries to do by imposing
their way on you I'm very open
empathetic and quite self aware of what
everybody thinks of me and pander to it
react to it and adjust to it but for
somebody to try to impose their way on
me without knowing me is just super not
interesting and so you
I was able to navigate through junior
high in high school and really not
struggle with peer pressure I just very
honestly thought I was better than
everybody I didn't act that way if you
go talk if you go find all the kids that
went to high school with me I don't
think any of them say that I walked
around with like I was cooler than them
you know that would've been very hard as
a 4 foot 11 freshman that was being made
fun of her not being 5 foot
it just it's how I thought inside and I
think if there's a lot of intestinal
fortitude to use a Gorilla Monsoon term
that's when wrestlers would get beat up
but then they would fight like the
Hulkster and macho man in Ultimate
Warrior that was the whole kind of like
genre the 80s get beat the crap out of
it and all of a sudden um and so that's
kind of how I am like I can take a lot
and then all of a sudden like you know
fight back and so you know there's
nothing I can say other than when you're
15 now when you're 51 or when you're 91
you're going to be stunned how little
you care how little it mattered and this
includes your parents and your siblings
and even your children this is an
intense thing this is a very intense
thing but if I could if I could wish
anything besides health on people
there's a lot I say this I say this
saying a lot there's a lot of traits I
like self-awareness everything but man
there's an unbelievable happiness that
comes along with self belief and and
recognizing how this plays out and let
me tell you how it plays out Prince as
he was taking his last breath as a big
shout out to Prince I'm a huge fan I
don't think Prince cared what billboard
magazine said or what anybody said it's
just the way it is it's the way it is
and so if through this plea on this show
on 201 on a Monday in late spring that
if I could get four of you to understand
if I could get four of you to understand
it's just not going to matter when
people I mean I love when people I don't
even want us to tell you I'm gonna say
it very clear I just let Stefan get very
focused here because I want to really
deliver this with all the drama that it
deserves and I like when people put me
down I get off on when people put me
down
nothing is more interesting to me than
to prove all of you wrong I love the
people that think I'm a huckster
or I've got some hidden agenda or I'm
not that good or I won't be that great
or I think too big of myself or my dad
at a liquor store and that's the only
reason I'm successful or I got lucky or
that the debt the debt that the debt
that show me like please please please
continue to judge me and underestimate
me because it's the only driver I have
and that's how I'm wired and I don't
expect all of you to be wired that way
but if I can through my energy move any
of you and trust me I'm reading your
comments because your comments are my
oxygen and I see so many of you so many
comments over the last three or four
months of people saying hey I've got a
little more cockiness or confidence than
I used to in fact I see it in you guys I
can only see my inner circle have more
confidence when they're like it just
rubs off any you're getting cocky have
you felt it yeah I know I know I them
but it's true right there there's a rub
off its kind of like a leader on a
sports team like it rubs off and one of
the great accomplishments in my life
will be the fact that I was able to rub
off my confidence not only on my inner
circle but on the community that decided
to give me it's unbelievable how good I
feel that I get to reward the amazing
reward that you give me which is in all
the things that you could be watching
right now you're watching this and all
the things you could be reading spending
time on time you've decided to watch me
me you know how incredibly empowering
that is it's at scale it's not three
people you know empowering that is and
for me knowing that not only do I give
you tactical advice or in a funny way
that I answer question number three a
girl in Indonesia might say well if Gary
Vee is bad at math and has been
successful I can - or in this ending
rant you can care a little bit less what
your coworker or your older brother or
that naysayer says or what I know so
many of you deal with which is the
trolling and the hate and the and the
disagreeing even when it's done well and
I love when people disagree with me in
the comment section I take it forward
this even when that happens you know
pissed I was a daily be thirty how many
people like in
Atika Lee were drilling me for a bad
episode fine but like after all like and
that's fine and I agree and we didn't do
a good job setting that up and I don't
think I set up the Iraq for success it's
a genre that he's not as passionate
about I could have done a better job I
understand that but it blows me away of
how much venom people can put up like
like after you provided you're only as
good as your last at-bat 200 great
episodes of a business show 30 great
episodes of the docq show five thousand
[ __ ] interviews of business stuff
unbelievable engagement answer your
questions answering your snaps boom one
baseball fantasy thing and pure and
utter disagreement dis parchment hate
negativity that's hard I'm the most
confident and it felt bad and I didn't
like it so what do I expect from others
I get it but it is what it is and at the
end of the day it's not going to matter
and you have to love yourself first and
feel good and complete with yourself
first
so as a 15 year old I would do what I
did as a 15 year old would you start
building those skills and not listen to
your parents and not listen to your
teachers and not listen to your friends
respect it but don't let anybody anybody
impose their way on you it's you you're
with yourself and you've got to make
yourself happy first Yeah right
you're inspired thanks Ania the rock
were you inspired you're so used to it
kidding yeah
like real cynical right that's what
happens out of it you know it was it
wasn't confidence it was see what he
just did he just did exactly one other
segment right you two are switching all
right great that's it right question of
the day what should I ask what are you
when you you guys interested anything
and are you interested actually Devan
India unity rocket asks question day I'm
not very passion about it start with
Iraq um all right tough guy all right
you've got a lot of time to favorite uh
and why that's a good one because d-roc
wants some quantum qual data India I
want to know who your baseball team is
and we're rooting for alright awesome
you're in a baseball mood guys thanks
for watching 201 woo 201 and like it's
like the next the next grade right like
isn't how they do in college 101 like
econ 101 we come to it yeah you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
[Music]